let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
on tuesday may 24th 19 young children
and two adults were killed in a school
shooting in uvalde texas it took over 90
minutes to stop the shooter but it has
now been revealed that some police
officers breached the school to get
their own children out before
the shooter was taken down
[Music]
texas law enforcement officials have
changed their stories so many times i
wouldn't be surprised if we find out
they personally escorted the gunman into
the school this was the deadliest
american school shooting since the 2012
massacre at sandy hook elementary this
is the 27th school shooting this year we
have had 213 mass shootings in less than
six months of 2022. you don't need to be
enrolled in ron desantis school of band
mathematics to know how bad these
numbers are the uvalde shooting happened
just 10 days after the horrific shooting
at the buffalo supermarket on may 14th
we unfortunately live in a country where
guns outnumber people and gun violence
has become an everyday occurrence the
correlation between the number of guns
in america and the number of gun related
debts in america is undeniable maybe
this slaughtering of innocent children
is a wake-up call for republicans they
are the pro-life party after all and
they've said on multiple occasions they
want to save the children i'm sure by
now texas senator ted cruz has offered a
solution one of the things that that
everyone agreed is don't have all of
these unlocked back doors have one door
into and out of the school i'm sorry
what was that have one door into and out
of the school his solution to mass
shootings is one door i mean why stop
there let's make it a doggy door instead
that's small enough for children to fit
through you know for a brief moment i
really thought ted cruz was gonna be
helpful
and then i remembered that ted cruz also
tried to ban dildos okay forget cancun
cruz let's try texas attorney general
ken paxton we need to continue to try to
focus on preventing this we we can't
stop bad people from doing bad things
they're going to violate murder laws
they're not going to follow gun laws
i've never understood that argument but
we are we can't harden these schools we
can create points of access that are
difficult to get through we can
potentially arm and prepare and train
teachers and other administrators to
respond quickly because the reality is
we don't have the resources
to have law enforcement at every school
hold on the gop who is notorious for
banning books and not giving teacher
school supplies wants to give teachers
guns instead giving teachers guns and
placing armed guards in schools does not
protect students from mass shootings in
fact one study found that schools with
armed guards were more likely to have a
higher death hold during a mass shooting
but in ken paxton's fantasy world a
teacher arrives on their first day at
remington rifle elementary and goes
through their classroom checklist
construction paper check erasers check
nine millimeter smith and wesson check
and then of course when that plan
ultimately fails arming those children
that republicans forced women to birth
is their backup plan because nothing
stops a bad guy with a gun like a child
with a gun and i can see it now little
timmy goes off to school with his
bulletproof backpack an ar-15 in a toy
story lunchbox full of bullets i'm sorry
but the fact that we live in a country
that assumes a random civilian should
risk their own life to save another is
incredibly deranged but now that i think
about it maybe we shouldn't take advice
from the guy that's currently being
investigated by the fbi also how did
this guy just win his primary anyway why
don't we just go further up the
leadership chain and try texas governor
greg abbott oh here's a tweet from
abbott where he talks about gun
ownership i'm embarrassed texas number
two in nation for new gun purchases
behind california let's pick up the pace
texans at nra okay that's embarrassing i
didn't fully read the tweet until right
now okay here's a video of abbott
signing gun legislation in 2021 i'm sure
this prevents future shootings i'm
signing seven laws to protect second
amendment rights in the lone star state
joined by lieutenant governor dan
patrick house speaker dave phil and
several republican lawmakers and members
of the national rifle association that
new laws will expand gun rights for
texans the first law he signed is what
was being called the constitutional
carry bill which gets rid of the
licensing and training requirement for
texans who are 21 years or older to
carry a pistol those who believe and
support second amendment rights we
support the right of every law-abiding
american to be able to have a weapon to
defend themselves jesus christ does any
texas lawmaker actually care about human
life don't answer that the sad truth is
there have been eight mass shootings in
texas over the past 13 years all while
lawmakers have steadily loosened
restrictions on carrying firearms
marjorie taylor green and every other
deplorable republican want to point
fingers and blame others like they're
just playing a game of clue i'm sorry to
ruin the game but it was not professor
woke in the library with crt it was the
gun it's always been the [ __ ] gun
republicans love to blame mental illness
for mass shootings so if it's such a
problem like they say it is then why
haven't they done anything to care for
those suffering if it's such a problem
why did trump make it easier for those
with mental illness to get guns when he
rolled back an obama regulation if it's
such a problem why didn't they say no
i'll tell you why it's because
republicans don't care about you or
anyone else so when exactly will
republicans start carrying 500 mass
shootings per year 800 a thousand how
many more innocent lives have to die
because of some weird fetish that
republicans have with guns ninety
percent of americans support background
checks on gun purchases but republican
politicians they're holding our country
hostage at gunpoint we are tired of
waiting we need to vote these
politicians out of office because if we
don't they will continue to send their
empty thoughts and prayers and happily
take donations from the nra and speak at
their conventions just days after a mass
shooting where children were murdered
the time for gun reform is past due we
need to stand up and make our voices
heard a great example of this is when
beta o'rourke confronted greg abbott at
his conference for the uvalde mass
shooting excuse me
excuse me
you're out of you're out of line and an
embarrassment
next shooting is right now and you're
doing nothing no he needs to get his ass
out here this isn't the place to talk to
him this is totally predictable
sir you're out of line
sir you are online i'm sure you are
online please leave this auditorium
i leave you with this in a world of greg
abbott's
be a better or work
[Music]
i know right it's it's crazy but i want
to bring in
ben hernandez ben benjamin how are you
doing well yo oh great great great it's
great to have you um
benjamin you actually were
in a restaurant um with ted cruz and
asking him about some of these questions
that jim acosta was actually asking um
the judge in our nra board member here
what what was your what was your main
question did you did you have a set of
questions that you wanted to ask ted
cruz i mean
what what what message were you trying
to send
i mean i think the message that i was
trying to send is very simply can we do
the most basic things
around gun control and i think to me you
know his answers or lack of answers
tells me a lot right i have a lot of i
have a lot of thoughts on guns and what
we could do and everything that we need
to do i didn't start there i said okay
let's start with background checks can
we start with there that because
it has the support of the majority of
the american public can we do that and
to not hear
and answer
on that you know blaming the democrats
and this and that i'm like man i'm not
talking about the democrats i'm talking
about you you're my elected official
right so so that's what i was trying to
get across is like can we do something
basic on this if you don't want to do
something you know you don't want to do
everything that i think we should do is
can we start where there's common ground
on this
so tell us a little bit about your
background because this isn't the first
time that you've thought that you woke
up and thought about
um the issue of gun safety and the issue
of
maybe common sense
reform if you will this isn't the first
time you thought it so tell us about
your background tell us how you've come
to
to even
confront ted cruz to ask him these
questions your elected official ask him
for the answers to your questions
you know i feel this has been
certainly was a couple of days in the
making you know i was there at the
protest outside the georgia brown
convention center with indivisible
houston you know
my buddy daniel cohen we we went uh the
day on thursday we went and we put a cut
out of ted cruz in front of the nra's
doors you know said we wrote on his
chest you know i murdered teachers and
children because his inaction
effectively is doing this right and we
put it in front of the doors and so you
know that i was in that mode for a
couple of days but also like
you know i since
2018
after santa fe
this blue wristband i've been wearing it
i got it at a march for our lives event
here in houston i've been wearing that
wristband every single day
since 2018 as a reminder to myself
right that we have not done anything
meaningful on gun violence in this
country and so for me it's just been
years of
building up and saying we haven't done
anything we need to do something and
that's
kind of what you said in um to him at
the restaurant i actually had a clip
here uh let's uh pull that up and now
this video is shot is it by someone who
is who is with you is that is that what
i understand yeah so my wife and i were
having dinner at sound sushi we were
wrapping up the dinner when uh i turn
over and i look and like ted cruz is
walking and i'm like you gotta be
kidding me right like you you're not
just gonna go and after you've already
speak at the end of the convention like
nothing and then go out for for for for
for dinner you know like and come into
the space where i am at
and not hear from me right right um and
so that's that was a thought so she was
the one who who captured the whole
interaction on video well it's about two
minutes and 20 seconds is the video here
on the internet and i believe it goes
from where you are
taking a selfie with ted cruz um to the
end to where they're actually escorting
you out of the restaurant um so let's
let's watch a bit of this and then i'll
let you comment and tell us more about
this interaction because
um the video that first went viral we
showed earlier it was kind of from a
bystander and they caught the very end
they didn't get this part so i want to
make sure we show this
okay you ready
okay hold on
all right one
two three
go
we're good
yeah we got it
is
um yeah
he he actually says the words to you
you're not listening to me and i don't
think your intent was
was to hear him out i think you know his
intentions you know what his opinions
are on these things i don't think it's a
secret that ted cruz takes money from
the nra and is going to stand with the
nra because they they fill his coffers
with money
he wasn't listening to you um and i
think that's probably
why texans should see this moment this
moment in the clip not the moment where
you know you got very passionate at the
very end and they they took you out to
get it to get you away from him because
he didn't want to speak to you anymore
but i think
the main issue here is that ted cruz
is not listening he's not hearing and i
don't believe it's just ted cruz i think
it's greg abbott i think it's dan
patrick i don't think it's just the
politicians that you have elected in the
state of texas i think there's
politicians all over this country who
are not listening they're only telling
us what we're supposed to do not
actually listening to what we want to
have done like that's the whole point of
a democratic constitutional republic
give us your thoughts on that yeah
absolutely i mean that's the tragedy
here right you know in the face of
something like uvalde where you should
be listening to people and listening to
what we could do to prevent
uh you know another
mass shooting where elementary children
died you know you're not even willing to
listen you're trying to give me the same
canned response that you gave earlier in
the week you know that was like what was
so offensive to me is like talking about
the democrat like i don't care about the
democrats man you're ted cruz like i
want to know what you will do and if you
can get behind something like this
you're not you know at some point later
i think he calls me ignorant like
like you just met me i've been watching
you for a minute i've been listening to
you as my representative for a very long
minute and you're gonna call me ignorant
based on this interaction i wasn't
offended that he called me anywhere but
it tells you a lot about how he thinks
of people and his constituents right
instead of saying like okay let me
listen to you what what what should we
do benjamin right and i'm here to listen
right right but you you want to throw
these canned responses and deflect
responsibility i wasn't having it you
know and i'm not gonna let you go and
give me your spiel and do the same thing
you've done over and over because you
came into the space where i was having
dinner right and you thought that was a
safe space i don't know why but here's
what's interesting he directs me to his
nra speech you know to go ahead and
watch that you know in his speech he
complains about the elites who live in
gated communities and have private
security you know you know who kicked me
out of that restaurant his private
security
there could be no place closer to the
gated upscale communities of houston
than we were dining that night and so
i'm like really
that's that's your response when you're
the one who's actually doing these
things gaslighting the rest of us well
yeah i think i think you completely hit
it on the head right there like the gas
lighting i mean we've seen it again and
again right it is like you know when he
gave the interview with sky news he said
i'm sorry you feel that way right i'm
sorry you don't like american
exceptionalism or whatever you said
right like it's that dismissive quality
of politicians especially republicans
who say i'm here to listen i'm here to
care you know i'm here for you and then
immediately
we'll say
you know
you you think what you think and you
feel how you feel but i'm really not
going to change the opinion i have or at
least i'm not going to change opinion
based on the nra payroll that i'm on but
i think the other thing too is like yeah
you know he says go and watch this
speech that i gave today at the nra you
go back and watch his speech or or
or trump's speech and you see in there
that they keep hitting the same thing
which is
one single point of entry we need high
security we need guards we need teachers
armed we need uh to really go after the
mentally ill and lock them up in mental
institutions and then the other one is
also how you know we need to um
we need to not ban guns and it's the
democratic policies that would actually
cause more or if anything the policies
that they're introducing or or have
suggested would actually do nothing
you know the where the party the
democrats are the party that uh have not
contributed anything to the conversation
when in fact if you look at there are
literal receipts things are introduced
into the floor and said hey let's vote
on this and they say
no we're not going to but you know
that's that's a good point gabe because
there was a time in our history and i
think people it and it was recent
history where the democratic party had
an arm of their party that they really
did take a lot of money from the nra
they did
they did stop any kind of common sense
gun laws
the the shift
in the political spectrum though
is that most people have common sense
thoughts around firearms like it's not
uncommon for someone who is even an nra
member themselves to have common sense
thoughts
around gun safety and what we should and
should not do in this country when it
comes to
guns especially
these assault style guns
the the shift is and i think this is
where they're losing their narrative
when they're talking about banning back
doors the shift in the politics is that
there's only one party that actually has
the backbone to stand against a handful
of families in this country who
manufacture these weapons because that's
really what we're up against here we are
up against a handful of families very
wealthy families who have inherited
these manufacturers in this country that
absolutely do not care what happens to
other people in this country as long as
they get to get their profits from the
technology that they have been able to
develop throughout the decades and they
want to put it on our streets for pure
blooded profit excuse the pun but that
is truly what is happening is we we have
got ourselves in a situation where only
one political party is willing to
protect those handful of families
to
put their technology that their
companies that they inherited that they
own
on the streets no matter what the
consequence and that is really where
we're at in the political game here and
that is why i believe that people like
ted cruz won't listen because if they do
start listening they're going to realize
that the money that they take is blood
money it is the blood is on their hands
and they're they're definitely not
um strong enough they're cowards to
admit that and he doesn't admit it in
this video i wanna i wanna finish it up
here because he really does get cowardly
here when you really start to uh talk
about things well i think as soon as he
looks over and realizes your wife is
recording still that's what like there's
that look of like
uh okay we gotta we gotta deal with the
situation right now
so let let's finish here um and then
i'll let you tell us about what happened
after the video because that's what i'm
really interested in because we don't
see the the after what what what ensued
after if there was anything
did you know
that no you know that but you stand here
you stand at that you stand at the nra
convention it is harder it is harder
when there are more guns
[Music]
why
why when 19 children died 19 children
died
it's on your hands that is on your hands
right through that one journey
so benjamin
i want to tell you that i think you
speak for a lot of americans um in this
video
um when especially at the end when
you're saying that it's on his hands
because he said things and um to you
that like oh the democrats are
filibustering um it's the democrats
democrats democrats when he is
public
right
his party has a lot of control so much
control over the state of texas and the
gun laws in the state of texas
that greg abbott cheered
cheered when they passed a law and and
was was was actually upset that that
california had more gun sales than texas
um
and i think you speak for most people
out there most parents especially when
they see the tragedy that it's not just
happened in uvalde um sandy hook uh
el paso
marjory stoneman douglas in parkland
florida i mean the list goes on and on
and on here that that at some point at
some point something has to be done but
what i what i want to know here
is
we kind of get the end of the video um
and i don't know if it's because twitter
will only let a 2 minute and 20 second
video be posted or if this video
continued what what actually happened
once you left the restaurant um can you
tell us a little bit about that was did
ted cruz reach out to you at all as he
said look i want to have a conversation
i want to have a reasonable discussion
with you i mean has he reached out at
all his team reached out at all do you
no no i mean his his uh
private security was the one who kicked
me out of the restaurant a lot of people
think it was a restaurant it wasn't it
was just two people from his security
and and uh
you know somebody sitting at his table
um but no one like you know when we get
there to the door i'm like no i'm
leaving man because that one of the
securities like you want to get arrested
i'm like i'm leaving man i'm leaving
right you know
what like what i mean like what on what
because you talk to him
i mean that's that's what they do right
my goal is like
you know what was more important to me
was to make sure that
i let ted cruz know that he's
responsible for his inaction right and
so once i said that and and they got me
to the door i was going to leave anyways
right right no interest in sharing a
space with ted cruz beyond every you
know second that i have to
and so yeah we left and then i looked
down at my shoe and i was like what why
am i wearing flip-flops turns out i
ripped my shoe in the process the sole
of my shoe because i was pushing so hard
to stand my ground and hold my place
while they're yanking me that i ended up
ripping my shoes so that that could tell
you like i don't know that the video
captures that but a lot of force was
going into that and then you saw the
moment when i turned on like who's
holding me man like i'm trying to i'm
just trying to have just trying to talk
to him yeah we're trying to talk to him
you guys are you guys are the aggressors
here ted cruz is the one who is play you
know and that and the same thing
happened in the sky news interview where
like you got like you guys are you know
arm and arm taking the photo or like the
photo but just like in the sky news like
he's the one who is going to take more
advance on putting his hands on you to
be like look that's that's nice and all
but i'm not going to really care for it
and like they're the aggressors they're
the ones who are now con you know
you know checking you they're the ones
that are pulling you back
right so i i don't know if there's some
sort of case for you here but like that
is something too it's like they're the
ones that technically kind of
made the physical touch they made the
assault on you so
yeah i don't know
well i i appreciate you um standing your
ground and really making your voice be
heard let me ask you if ted cruz's
office did reach out if they did reach
out and want to have a conversation with
him i don't think you you wouldn't be
afraid to have a conversation with ted
cruz in private or in public would you
private or in public better for me in
public because more people need to hear
the answers right i was asking questions
that that people people
want answers to so i'd love that
opportunity
because it was unresolved you didn't
give me an answer right about a simple
thing i have a lot of thoughts about you
know what we should do about gun
regulations in this country but i wasn't
going to all of my thoughts i was going
to the simple thing where i know a
majority of americans are behind and so
yeah let's have that conversation and
let's make it public why not well what
are you afraid of right um so i'd love
that opportunity yeah because you say
what are you afraid of but of course for
him he's like i'm afraid of everything
right why i mean obviously in the in the
confrontation that was caught on uh
several different cameras in
in the restaurant there um that he was
very uncomfortable with not not only
just hearing the things that you had to
say but having to to formulate answers
that was other than his
you know his go-to's democrats fault
um you know
more guns
is the answer you know this
because they continue on this
this this idea and they they're really
losing ground on some of their arguments
like they're back to the reason why we
have to have ar-15s as wild hogs like
literally that is where they're back to
in some of these arguments matt gatz was
tweeting it the other day that the
reason why our constitutional right
affords us to have ar-15s is because we
have we have feral hogs in certain parts
of the country like we've had barrel
hogs in this country for hundreds of
years and we didn't have ar-15 style
right i also wasn't aware that we had
that many hog hunters out there right
like well and here's the thing i i
actually am not against someone who
wants to
uh hunt wild game to have the kind of
weapons that they need to have i just
believe that someone should actually be
responsible and held accountable for
those weapons to hunt with those weapons
for wild game i mean if you really need
a rifle that has a high capacity
magazine um to shoot wild game i come
from a rural area i went deer hunting as
a kid i we didn't we we took deer rifles
that held six shots and really honestly
that was that was triple doing it i mean
if you had to shoot twice
um at a whitetail deer because whitetail
deer are not heavily armed they don't
wear body armor i mean this is wild game
and if you need more than two maybe
three shots
you probably need to pick a different
recreation or just or just go to the
shoot yes head back to the shooting
range and just saying maybe
there for a little bit but but that
their arguments are falling apart here
with the back door talk um how do you
feel when they when they do this thing
where they try to distract from every
because you said you went to several
march of uh of our lives and i think um
david hogg actually announced was it
yesterday i believe that they're going
to go to dc yeah on june 11th uh which
um
i've already suggested they gave that we
live stream that um that rally or parts
of that rally but uh depending on the
time of day and the stuff uh how long it
is but we want to try to live stream
that to get that out to everybody but
how do you feel about some of this
dodginess of the of the actual issue
when they talk about back doors and
hardening our schools as if our children
should go to prisons to be educated
i mean i think that that's why i say
like you know like ted cruz just has to
be the unluckiest guy because like you
know
i wasn't having any of that right like i
think that's why people i've heard
people like wow you interrupted him you
don't talk yeah damn right because when
he was trying to give me those canned
answers i wasn't having i was like stop
like i'm not interested in that let's go
to background checks that's what i'm
asking you about give me an answer on
that give me an answer on that give me
and so i wasn't trying to let him escape
because you know i've seen what they do
and i don't i don't have any patience
for that right like i don't like i don't
have patience that i don't want your
canned answer i'm asking you a very
simple question why can't you get behind
something that the majority of americans
can get behind right and you don't have
an answer i don't have patience for your
garbage answers and there are garbage
answers because in the face of tragedy
that's all you can come up with right i
don't have time well and he's he's
here's the thing he's probably not also
the one that's coming up with the
answers right he's going to the nra or
the nra's coming to him and the
spokesperson says listen you're going to
have to run through these three bullet
points don't ever mention these things
but definitely keep reiterating these
things we want to distract away because
it's not the guns it's the back door or
it's the teacher or it's you know the
fact that we you know we don't have high
walls or
you know barbed wire fencing right
that's the problem it's not the fact
that we have more guns than people in
this country and then getting one is
probably more you know it's easier than
buying a pack of cigarettes or buying a
lotto ticket yeah exactly benjamin i
appreciate you being in this fight as
many parents in this country do
um and i hope you continue to stay and
you continue to stay vocal and i
actually hope i i i actually am hoping
that you get a chance to talk to ted
cruz um one on one in a situation where
you can get some of the answers to your
questions he is your representative i
feel like he owes you um the time just
five ten minutes to sit down with you
and answer some of the questions that he
was
clearly unable to answer in the
restaurant there benjamin tell us where
where our viewers can find you where
they can follow you because i know
you're you're gonna stay in this fight
um and it's vitally important that
everyone stick together um to make sure
that that this country's safe
yeah definitely follow me on twitter at
you see the handle there the benjamin
hdz um you know another thing that i
want to talk about is yeah the last
couple of days here a lot of people have
asked me you know like i said they say
you're here i'm like man i'm just doing
what i needed to do
but a question has come you know the
natural question is like how can
we do this with our elected officials
and i think like with the indivisible
houston group you know uh i think one
thing that we're gonna do two nights
from now on thursday we're in a live
stream um sort of a a a a conversation
when one we're gonna take people through
the you know how we got to it answer the
question everybody wanted wants to know
it was this stage right i'm like no like
y'all like answer that question so take
people through the video the behind the
scenes but then also
leave them with
if you want to how can you do this with
your elected officials and create that
playbook to challenge them because the
reality is when they're hiding like ted
cruz behind private security and in his
gated community even though that's what
he accuses other people of you know when
they're hiding when you find them in the
street challenge them and this is how
you should challenge them because
there's a way to do that right um you
know and so we're going to take people
through a playbook
um you know and give people and empower
people really to do this with their
elected officials and this is not a
partisan thing hell whether it's a
republican democrat independent
libertarian whatever it is if your
elected official isn't creating this
space
for constituents to ask questions and
they answer you go out and you make that
space if you see them on the street in
the grocery store at the theater or in a
restaurant you create that space because
they're actively hiding from us when
they represent us
well thank you thank you
yeah tell us tell us where that's going
to be
yeah we're going to stream it we uh have
a the details in a couple of hours but
we're going to stream it on facebook
live um and also on youtube but you'll
you'll see details right there from my
handle coming out in a couple of hours
okay and then also something invisible
houston handle um you know because we we
a lot of people are asking like yeah we
need to do this how do we as much after
watching better o'rourke do it as well
right confronting greg but i think
there's there's there's a movement
that's starting that people say wait a
minute i don't have to be
passive in this conference this is a
conversation and i need to make space
for myself and we need to make them have
this conversation i agree with you so so
when you when you tweet that out
everyone go follow ben uh at the
benjamin hdz on twitter the handle's
there on the screen um we'll put it in
the the chat as well here um so so go
follow benjamin on twitter and benjamin
if you can send that to me or gabe and
we'll try to retweet it out to see if we
can get that out to as many people as as
we possibly can and get the audience to
help us circulate that around so that
way anyone who wants to watch um that
live stream can do that thank you for
joining us i really and and and come
back please come back and give us an
update uh we want to talk to you more
about this issue
it's not going away and right now right
even even if there is some common sense
uh reform passed we still cannot take
our eye off the ball because
these these folks that are
that are out for the blood money of the
nra are not going to stop um it's
obvious that they're willing to do
almost anything give you any kind of
excuse they can't even blame a back door
for the events that happen
in uvalde the tragedy of the 19 dead
children and two dead teachers it's um
it's a shame that we have to do that so
thank you benjamin for joining us
everyone go check out
benjamin on twitter to make sure you
catch that live stream uh i i'm
interested and i think we might uh take
a look at that so we'll have you back
soon benjamin i appreciate it everyone
stick around we'll be right back thanks
so much for this break have a good one
benjamin thank you
june is going to be a huge month in
american politics because we're going to
hear about the january six select
hearings the public hearings you know
that we are going to stream them here on
the tony michael's podcast every single
one of them gavel to gavel but also in
the month of june we're expected to
receive the late decision from the
supreme court so this morning we find
out that the supreme court is requesting
the law clerks hand over their text
messages this is all distraction this is
distraction from the actual text
messages that we're going to see in
these public hearings from an actual
wife of a supreme court justice who was
trying to overturn the united states
government who was trying to commit a
coup that's right i said it jeannie
thomas and clarence thomas these q and
honors have infiltrated the supreme
court and it needs to be investigated if
we can investigate a stupid [ __ ] leak
of a decision that they're going to make
to take away our rights we absolutely
absolutely can investigate and should
investigate the coup attempt that
happened by the supreme court justice's
wife she was text messaging the chief of
staff all kinds of crazy ass q and stuff
we should not forget about this and we
should not believe or or [ __ ]
pay attention much to the distraction of
the leak i i would imagine that we're
going to find out that this leak
investigation is not going to lead down
the road that they want and the media is
buying all this [ __ ] distraction this
watch this hand while we do this other
thing watch this hand over here while we
commit a coup over here that's what it
is distraction they're gonna distract us
with the leak of a decision that they're
going to make think about this for a
second we're supposed to believe that
the high crime that has been committed
in the supreme court is that the
decision that they're gonna make to take
away women's rights and liberties of
their body that they have
constitutionally in this country right
now that that is the high crime that was
committed in the supreme court give me a
[ __ ] break forget about
buying and paying for the justices the
right-wing coots that are on the supreme
court forget about that that [ __ ]
crime in the first place how they bought
and paid for it through the federalist
society of making sure that minority
ideology rules in this country forget
about that for a second forget about how
we can't have 13 justices we have to
have nine which makes no sense we have
13 districts we should have 13 justices
that's the framing of the supreme court
it only makes common sense logic it's
not [ __ ] rocket science but forget
about that that part of it we're
supposed to believe that the high crime
that was committed in the supreme court
is someone leaked the decision that
they're gonna make this month we're not
supposed to believe that the wife of
supreme court justice who was texting
the chief of staff while the coup is
happening while the coup is ongoing
while donald trump tried to take over
our government rip up the constitution
and [ __ ] on it throw it in the toilet
and flush it i guess i don't know it
seems to be a trend but that's what
we're supposed to believe get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] and this
morning when this report comes out about
these staffers or some [ __ ] about text
messages we should be on a crusade folks
this morning yelling and screaming at
the top of our lungs continually and we
shouldn't stop again we're one issue
voters now we have to be one issue
voters because it is clear now more than
ever what their mission is their mission
is to take away our [ __ ] democracy
take away our right as a people to
decide how we can keep kids safe in a
school they want to take away our
[ __ ] right to do that they want to
take away our right as a people to make
sure that guns don't get into the wrong
hands and that maybe some of these guns
aren't manufactured in the first place
for pure profit they want to take away
our rights to our to our bodies women
don't even have the right to their
uterus in some states anymore to medical
decisions that are made between them and
their doctor about their life and we're
supposed to believe this morning that
the big huge controversy
that the big huge crime committed in
this country was a leak of a decision
that they're going to make it's not like
they're claiming oh my god this person
is lying who cares who leaked it is
probably a right winger in the first
place who gives a [ __ ] that's probably
what we're going to find out in the long
run this investigation and no
investigation ever works out well for
these right-wingers we've seen that i
mean remember how important a certain
email lady's emails were several years
ago remember how important hunter
biden's laptop is to the biden
presidency remember
give me a [ __ ] break these
investigations never [ __ ] pan out for
these morons and the reason why is
because they're always based in delusion
they spew [ __ ] out all their holes and
it will continue that way this morning
they're mad that these law clerks have
text messages get the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ] and the mainstream media
is buying this [ __ ] hook line sinker
hook line sinker don't buy it make the
noise of the real [ __ ] crimes that
are being committed in the supreme court
jeannie thomas the wife of clarence
thomas that piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] was
texting the chief of staff who was
standing next to the person who was
trying to overthrow our government and
encouraging it not only encouraging
giving them ideas on how to overthrow
our constitution and then and then
clarence thomas got to make decisions on
the evidence without recusing himself
you want to talk about [ __ ] crimes
they can't stop criming they can't stop
criming we can't take our eye off the
prize here folks the prize is our
democracy it is at stake every [ __ ]
waking moment we have to fight for it
everywhere because these fascists are
not going to stop
me right now that proud boys are not
allowed at this trump event i'm telling
you right now any sort of proud boys or
qan and cigna yeah has to go all right
here we go i'm gonna leave i'm gonna
leave but we were invited we were
invited to be here i'm going to walk out
they probably didn't tell you
we were walking out towards the doors
okay so why why why do i have to walk
why do i have to walk because the front
doors are this direction sure that's why
no i mean like why why do proud boys
have to watch well it's because you
can't have any logos or insignia for
this event and the people hosting this
event you're kidding me right because
the trump campaign gave us vip
shirt inside tickets or you can purchase
another shirt this is really happening
it's really happening okay okay so can i
ask why proud boys aren't allowed here
it's the logo it's the shirt and i don't
make them sorry
but we're we're giving you some options
is there is there a reason why proud
boys aren't allowed here it's a private
event and they made the rules man that's
all that's all i could say but the the
actual campaign themselves gave us vip
tickets so why is it
why can't
i watched a video yesterday
you see our title of our show is proud
boys cry more and these [ __ ] in-cell
white nationalists it is really it is
really something there's a couple videos
out there of the proud boys from this
nra convention one where that trump
basically told him to go [ __ ] themselves
um you know during the presidential
debate he's like stand back and stand by
now he's like no stand over there go
over there i don't want you anywhere
near me i look like a traitor when you
people are standing next to me i did
that's not a good look he won't even let
cueing on people in his entire [ __ ]
base his entire base the prowl boys and
q anon like that who who else is there
gonna vote for this [ __ ] who
else is gonna support this this clown
besides people who believe in cuinon the
crazy wackadoo [ __ ] and the proud boys
told them to go get [ __ ] and really
it's not about having the people in
right this has nothing to do with what
type of people they associate with they
really want to associate with white
nationalists they really want to
associate with terrorists domestic
terrorist groups like the proud boys and
the oath keepers they just don't want to
appear that way it would be really nice
proud boys if you guys didn't dress up
and do the cosplay proud boy thing you
know put on a different costume is what
he really wants them to do the same way
with the q anon he definitely wants the
q and on crazy he just doesn't want the
costuming he thinks it's gross he thinks
they look trashy he thinks they're not
classy coming from a guy who has gold
toilets have you ever seen pictures of
the inside of this guy's house you you
talk you talk about [ __ ] trashy holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] this guy is the epitome of
white class trash
no we're talking about the proud boys do
you think they really thought about that
name before they picked it out like i
don't think they did i mean here's the
thing their logo is
a [ __ ]
wait wait who's
the proud boys what what yeah no it's a
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait stop
stop hold up wait a minute you're
telling me because i i i'm not i i have
not done this much research into this
their logo is is designed after a penis
is that what you're saying
it's not after a penis it's a [ __ ]
rooster or whatever but oh a kite
[Music]
i thought you meant they were walking
around with penises all over them and no
who knows i mean i mean i'm not against
it i think i think that would actually
be funnier than the [ __ ] chicken
right but they have this [ __ ] rooster
right as their logo right so that's why
i say [ __ ] when they were like let's
name ourselves brown boys and they're
like what what mascot can we have that
represents us as proud boys manly men
who who absolutely are [ __ ] white
nationalists who hate right yeah they're
like
they're like what is more american farms
farmers are pretty american that's
pretty manly and they're like well
what's the thing that gets you up in the
morning and they're like you know
someone people like oh a little pill you
know somebody i'll be like oh it's a
rooster a [ __ ] rooster and then they
were like and then they're like oh yeah
yeah that's a good [ __ ] you know you
know what pisses me off about the proud
boy thing because we're joking about it
but what pisses me off is um the leader
gavin what the hell was his name yeah
gavin mcginnis gavin mcguinness the guy
you found didn't he didn't he like do
something with the dildo to prove that
he's not gay or some [ __ ] yes on on air
which i will not bring up the clip and
show on here because i'm sure we'll get
flat for it right yeah youtube might not
like that to prove that gavin mcginnis
was not gay he shoved a dildo into his
ass on television live streamed it what
pisses me off about that kind of [ __ ] is
that these people believe that it's the
it's somehow like the physical sex and
that's where they get this they they
start these tropes with lgbtq people
that they're predators and [ __ ] because
they think it's like it's not always
about the physical sex you [ __ ] idiot
like they love a person yeah they have
feelings for a person they have
attraction to a certain person and a
certain gender
they really because they're so
frightened of their own insecurities
that they don't understand that it
almost feels like to me you know we joke
about it but it almost feels like to me
they were trying to
steal away the the pride that someone
would have to not be afraid to express
their sexuality express their their
identity i am excited that it is pride
month and don't let the prowboy steal
this away even though that name is now
associated with uh domestic terrorists
and white nationalists
we see this morning susan collins
says oh democrats and republicans
there's some common ground apparently
susan collins thinks that guns have
learned their lesson learn their [ __ ]
lesson just like the rest of the people
that she capitulates to makes excuses
for
susan collins we don't care about your
common ground that's not what we're
concerned about we're not concerned
about common ground in the senate
between republicans and democrats
there's plenty of common ground out here
90 percent
you dumb [ __ ] 90
of people are for a bill that your
caucus is blocking you republicans
common ground my [ __ ] ass a grocery
store a church
an elementary school
a hospital
what next restaurant now we've had those
movie theater ah we had those two what
next where to next common ground it's a
good thing bunch you senators
republicans have decided that there's
common ground somewhere and these guns
has learned their lesson it really is
not difficult and it gets easier and
easier every day to see exactly what is
happening because there was a question
about this gun what kind of gun is it is
a shotgun is it a rifle is it a handgun
what kind of gun is it what kind of gun
is it the media's waiting the media's
waiting politicians are waiting to find
out if this is a military of course it's
a military-style weapon what in the why
the [ __ ] would someone take any other
kind of gun into a shooting to kill
multiple people why why would they do
that that's like taking a 1992 dodge
caravan to a drag race the [ __ ] are you
talking about of course of course
they're going to get the best weapon
they can to apply the maximum amount of
damage that's the point well they're
mentally ill yeah probably you're not
gonna do anything about that either
common ground susan collins you dumb
[ __ ] if you want more of a
reason i don't know to participate in
your democracy and figure out uh how can
we work this around where the majority
of ideology right the majority of
american opinion on policy not opinion
anyways just on policy like i don't know
common sense gun safety just common
[ __ ] sense we did a whole show on it
yesterday you're killing us by putting
these [ __ ] weapons in the hands of
people who should not have them how in
the [ __ ] can't we figure this out doors
dildos it's porn matt walsh wants to
blame it on lgbtq community destroying
our country monkey pots all kinds of
[ __ ] nonsense it's the gun you dumb
[ __ ] it's the [ __ ] gun it is
not difficult to understand what is
happening in this country it is not tony
there's other country that have these
guns that don't have these problems they
just they don't they ban backdoors in
porn they don't have porn they don't
have dildos they don't have condoms life
begins at a boner and women can't vote
don't you know this that's what we need
to do in this country you understand
what they're trying to do right you get
it right you understand what these
fascists are trying to do like matt
walsh tucker carlson greg abbott ron
desantis they're using your fear and
your arguments for guns to do nothing to
spiral us into fascism a lot [ __ ]
quicker by blaming it on porn and dildos
and trans people and wokism and woke
teachers and snowflakes as if they're
not the biggest snowflakes in the entire
[ __ ] world get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] it is the access to the
gun the gun the gun the gun the gun you
dumb [ __ ] how can you tie
fascism to people who just want their
second amendment right it's not your
second amendment right it is not your
second amendment right to have the
weapons to go into a hospital a grocery
store a school a church a theater a
restaurant a bowling alley an office
building a post office a community
center it is not your [ __ ] right to
access that gun as fast as possible so
you can go kill as many as possible you
are [ __ ] deluded you are deranged you
are a [ __ ] idiot pluck your [ __ ]
head out of your goddamn ass
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking